آه ، لقد قمت بتقديمك إلى
هذا الشخص التالي الذي جعل هذا الشخص المسكين
يعاني من أشياء من
كوابيسي ، اسمها جيسي شار ،
اعتقدت أنها فازت بالجائزة الكبرى في رحلة طيران جيت بلو
من لوس إلى لونج بيتش كاليفورنيا
إلى منزلها في سان  فرانسيسكو عندما
كان لديها مقعدين مفتوحين بجانبها ، وهذا
هو الحلم في أي رحلة طيران على JetBlue ، يمكنك الحصول
على الطريق بالكامل لنفسك ولكن بسبب
رعبها وأنا بصراحة ، هذا ما
حدث بعد ذلك ، ألق نظرة على هذه الصورة ،
نعم هذا صحيح ، لقد
ذهب هذا الخنزير الصغير  لتسويق هذا
الخنزير الصغير بقي في المنزل وهذا
الخنزير الصغير في المقعد خلفها صعد على متن
طائرة JetBlue وقررت السماح
لكل شيء بالخروج فقط
والسماح لهم بالطيران
لينضموا إلي الآن الروح التعيسة المسكينة
التي تحملت هذه الإهانة إلى  كل الإنسانية
وجهت جيسي لجيسي شكراً لك
لوجودك معنا ، لقد كنت أشعر بالدموع
من أقدام عارية على متن الرحلات الجوية لسنوات ، لذلك
عندما رأيت هذا شعرت بألمك
واضطررت للتحدث معك ما حدث ، انتظر ،
أعني ذلك  هل فعلت ذلك حتى عندما
لاحظت هذه القدمين لأول مرة ، لذلك
تركت مساند الذراعين عمدًا
على طائرتي أو في صفي لأعلى حتى أتمكن من
الاستمتاع بمقعدي الواسع في السماء ولكن
بعد وقت قصير من الإقلاع لاحظت أن
أحد مساند الذراعين  سقطت
ظننت أنها كانت مجرد حالة جاذبية
ولكن عندما نظرت من فوق رأيت هذا النوع
من مجموعة أصابع القدم السربنتين هذه تتأرجح
من الطريق خلفي أوه بقدم واحدة
أول اختبار حقيقي للماء هو في
القدم التالية
كيف يفعلون بعد  نعم ، أقول
أي شيء لهذا الشخص لم أكن
أرغب في الحصول على مضيفة طيران
لأنني أردت أن يشهد شخصًا آخر هذا
يحدث ، أعني أنني كنت وحدي في صفي ،
لذا لا يوجد أحد في الجوار وأنا
وأنا قلقون من عدم تصديق أحد
إذا كنت قد أخبرتها للتو وانتظرت
مجيء مضيفة طيران ، لكن بحلول الوقت الذي
جاء فيه شخص ما أخيرًا ،
نزل نوع المقعد من حيث
أتوا ، حسنًا ، لذا فقد تراجعوا
عن أسنانهم الهوبيت ، نعم ولكن
ليس unti  l بعد فتح
وإغلاق النافذة يرتجف مع
عدم ظهور أقدامهم ، يجب أن أذهب حقًا إنه
حقيقي لقد حدث حقًا
يا